so next we have a group discussion
from um a group of panelists so here we
have um mr elia brodsky the co-founder
and ceo of pine biotech we also have dr
raja guthrakuta
a professor of astronomy and
astrophysics at uc santa cruz
dr japoliano chavez a postdoctoral
scholar at the university of chicago
and miss maria victoria luz a
bioinformatician from the university of
brasilia
so they're going to be discussing the
sip program
how they all got involved in the field
of bioinformatics and if they have any
advice for new bioinformaticians
so please welcome and uh
thank you uh laura i just before we jump
in i know that uh raja you you're going
to introduce us to the sip program
but before we jump into that
i just wanted to highlight the few
takeaways so far from all of these
wonderful presentations
so in the scope of today we heard from
people in india in africa in south
america in the u.s
people that come from life sciences as
well as computer sciences and we heard
how there is a common challenge of
uh introducing because this topic is
kind of central to our symposium
introducing bioinformatics at an early
stage many people don't realize the
significance
early on but later on as they continue
to pursue their research interests they
kind of rediscover the significance of
this skill set
and go on to apply it to a variety of
topics we we saw people that applied to
studying uh insects studying plants uh
bacteria
eventually pursuing cancer biotechnology
big data cloud computing so it seems
like the trajectories are very
unexpected
but what they all share in common is
that early exposure to bioinformatics
appreciation of the role of data in
biology and eventually uh kind of uh
learning how to utilize these skills to
pursue what they really enjoy what they
love what they care about
so that really emerged to me as a common
trend another important trend that i saw
was
really the diversity of what we call
bioinformatics i mean it ranges from
cloud computing like i mentioned all the
way to mathematical modeling like we
just heard right now uh to analyzing uh
kind of simple data
and very very complex data right so it's
really a term that encompasses a diverse
set of directions and uh and challenges
that it seeks to address
and my final takeaway from this is that
there are so many efforts to try to
introduce these topics early on
and a major question that arises for me
is
yes we are here because we're all
interested in bioinformatics what about
people that maybe are outside of the
circle you know people that don't
necessarily um you know tend to
enjoy research or or pursue research you
know how do they get exposed to these
things and how do we make that early
interaction fun meaningful
and leading to something effective later
on so with that summary uh raja over to
you
let me just make sure that you can
unmute yourselves
there you go
thank you thank you very much um
i know uh laura mentioned that i have
about 12 minutes to speak and a couple
of minutes of q a after that i have a
slide set
thank you for inviting me here i'm an
astronomy professor at uc santa cruz
what am i doing in a
biotechnology research symposium let me
explain um i got connected to
geocharifes
who was a grad student at uc santa cruz
when we got connected
because
we were involving high school students
in our research
um
jio connected me to elia
mind biotech and you know and to this
omix
research symposium 2022.
i have a few slides to share with you so
let me let me see if i can share my
screen there we go
um
are you able to see my slides now
yes we are okay thank you
um so uh
um
i will talk not so much about sip but
the crest umbrella programs and
initiatives and i'll tell you what rest
is in just a moment i'm i'm a professor
at um you see santa cruz i have the
misfortune of being department chair i
can't wait for that to end um and i've
been running the science internship
program for high school students and i
about seven years ago i spent eight
months at google and they really helped
me scale up some of the outreach work i
was doing
this work has been done in collaboration
with my colleagues at ucrc sarah
schneider christy tall and carolyn
roosevelt
what i'll talk about in a moment is
crest which stands for creating equity
and stem
santa cruz is a beach town i hope you
can see the shape of the crest of a wave
here but it's also the letter c r e s t
and it's an umbrella uh that is um you
know that sort of brings coherence to a
range of things we're doing here at
santa cruz and i i'm really grateful to
you for allowing me to share this this
is um
our bold title is creating equity in
steam
where steam is science technology
engineering art and mathematics
um are we going to create equity in my
lifetime or yours
probably not
are we going to create equity
with one person working on this probably
not but the whole idea is for us to join
hands
and that's what the symposium is about
join hands work together and work
towards this thing this is a bright
light in the distance but it can guide
us in our work and that's what i'm
hoping to talk about
um
why do this
um there are folks from india on this
call so i thought i would
mention something about the indian
cricket team
i'm a huge cricket fan and the indian
cricket team in the 60s and 70s when i
was following them were constantly
losing
in brazil on the other hand the
brazilian soccer team was constantly
winning
there was some difference in the
formulae
the indian cricket team when after every
loss the captain or you know the best
player on the team the person who had
put in their best performance would be
interviewed by the television or
newspaper in those days
and even though they had all grown up in
india they spoke to queen's english they
spoke perfect english
growing up in india playing cricket
now there's something wrong with that
picture right because you don't need to
speak english with a perfect accent in
order
you know the ability to do that and the
ability to bring it fling your body into
the air and take pluck the ball out of
thin air with your hands or to
good hand-eye coordination that has
nothing to do with the ability to speak
english
so um this changed for the indian
cricket team in 1983 where for the first
time they had a captain who could not
speak a single sentence of english
um you know he was an embarrassment in
front of the camera and the television
they had translators for him to
translate from
his native language
his native indian language
which was punjabi
to english
but guess what the indian cricket team
won the world cup in 1983 with this
captain i don't think these things are
this is a coincidence right when you
open your talent pool
so that
you're not just selecting people who can
speak perfect english and they're part
of an elite section of indian society
when you open your talent pool wider
than that you're going to get a wider
you're going to get better talent and
the brazilian soccer team realized this
a long time ago if you look at every
brazilian almost every brazilian soccer
star has you know not been from an elite
background almost all of them very few
have been from elite backgrounds
so diversity and excellence are not two
separate things they go hand in hand
um other thing i realize is working
we are working to diversify our
institutions but that requires working
outside the institutions we can't just
expect that people who apply to our
institutions as undergraduates graduate
students or faculty are going to be
representative of society around us if
we don't do the groundwork
if we don't bring ourselves our
university work to the outside world and
this is true for corporate organizations
as well we have to
we have to work outside to diversify the
insight
and i want to say that you know we are
we are going through a pandemic you know
overtime team but we're also in an
information pandemic where the value of
evidence-based thinking the value of the
notion of expertise has really eroded
and while there's a vaccination i just
took my fourth shot yesterday my pfizer
shot for covid19 and they give it to the
elderly first
because that's who's at risk for the
information pandemic where we've eroded
critical thinking the people who are
most at risk are the young people
because they're going to live with this
disease the longest
so we need to address that and programs
like these like jio and i are involved
in other vaccinations for young people
and it's a long game it's not a short
game it's not something that's going to
address the immediate needs of the
community it's not going to immediately
address hunger
or domestic abuse poverty it's not going
to address those things right away but
education is a long game
okay with that i'll get off my soapbox
and talk a little bit about what um like
a pattern i see when young people are
going to engage in steam the first thing
the most logical thing for them to do is
first gain access to the people and the
process and i've underlined people and
process here really because very often
when science is reported you see the gee
whiz results you don't see the the many
things that fail to get to that so
people in process are important for me
that access happened by going to a
planetarium as a kid or by watching
david attenborough's life on earth
then you need to build the skills and
then you can apply them in a controlled
setting but the mentor has already gone
down a path and they send other students
down the same path where they can
control the amount of instruction they
give them and then finally there's
open-ended research and the thing that
jio and i worked together on and said
involved open-ended research by
open-ended i mean the mentor has not
solved the problem before
there's no recipe to solve the problem
and you're engaging young people in that
process of learning from productive
failure
so creating equity in steam is something
we're trying to do and the words that
run across are what we're trying to
achieve
and the words that run up and down
critical thinking in the context of
open-ended research
under close mentoring is how we're
trying to achieve it so
the goal and the method goal across
method down
um so we first want to encourage young
people to dip their toes in the water
this is the access piece and i've been
running something called shadow the
scientists you know now when we get time
on i'm an astronomer so i use telescopes
telescopes on mauna kea telescopes in
california instead of going to the
telescopes we can't go to the telescopes
anymore because of the pandemic
what we do is operate the telescopes
from home
using vnc
using zoom to connect people
and what we started doing is encouraging
young people to join our zoom call to
see how we work you know this is this is
dipping your toe in the water this is
seeing you know
do i like the temperature of the water
do i like the people who are already in
the water and then if this is if you
like this then you have to learn the
swim strokes and this is something we've
been running a python and research
tutorial where you learn the techniques
jio has started this wonderful
r in the context of research and
computational biology the idea is to
teach young people the tools you know
computational tools
and
really embedding this in research what
we do here is we have code that's
directly relevant for a science project
and you can remove lines of code
and ask the student to write them back
in to make the code work again and what
you're doing there is you're teaching
them both about
coding but also about the application of
that coding once you have this then you
are ready to take a deep dive that's
what the science internship program is
it's open-ended research
10 weeks today is our application
deadline for our high school students so
it's too late if you know high school
students are interested today is the
deadline but we have over you know we
have over 2 000 applicants um we have a
second program that's in collaboration
with professor annette lee at arizona
state university that's at the
intersection of art science and culture
it's a different kind of deep type not
just into one science but into an
intersectional area then once you do
this program after this plunge what do
you do we have a network called the
sphere network which is stands for stem
programs for high schoolers engaging in
research early it's a way to connect
programs so that we're not each
reinventing the wheel
it's a way to create a community of
practice for mentors to engage high
school students in research we have an
alumni buddies program so near peer
mentoring we follow the trajectories of
our
interns we offer this to teachers in the
science internship program that's what
tcip is so that they can take this work
and
spread it to to their students in
schools we have a peer-to-peer college
and career network and we have community
college students and so
so that's the end of my slides that's my
12 minutes i'll stop here and see if
there are any questions thank you
okay i actually uh do have a couple of
questions um so the first one is
what is that critical thing that can
lead a student to go from following a
tutorial to starting with open-ended
research
you know i i can tell you what i've
found
and but others should chime in
i found the first time i was doing
research was when i was a grad student
but for younger people for high school
students and college students
what i've learned
is the first time they're participating
when they feel like they're
if not equal partners but at least
partners in the enterprise you know when
the mentor turns to them and say you
know what do you think of this part why
are we seeing this trend
that's a critical moment that's a
critical moment where you know that
you're not just doing this for someone
else you're being asked to think about
something you're you know close to an
equal participant in this that's been
that's what our students have told us
that when we felt like we were
participating but in a way that where
our opinion was valued as a scientist or
engineer
that tipped the scales for us that gave
us the confidence
to really feel like we have ownership
i think in other words raja a good way
to put it is the feeling of community
feeling
of being part of something maybe my way
of putting it is to feeling that you're
part of something bigger
for instance the one
one interest that i have
that motivated me for doing this type of
research that i do is the possibility
of caring people of helping people get
cared for the diseases that they face
and so
uh that's that's that's my motivation
that's the one thing that makes me never
give up on the
drawbacks that i that i kind of face
daily on on a day-to-day um
situation
because the
result of the effort that is going to be
put is going to be much better than the
whatever is costing
so i think that uh
from the beginning not from right now i
think the opportunity that i had that i
had on sip and that causes me to
strongly appreciate that is the fact
that this experience of belonging that i
have as a mentor can be shared with with
the students that come to to join the
program and in the
because of the philosophy of sip which
is in my mind is the thing that you have
taught us you have pioneered because of
the philosophy
the philosophy of sip
that becomes something that is offered
to the students i mean this mindset the
possibility of
feeling the belonging to the reasons to
the cause of research uh
is passed on to the students
very clearly in my opinion
did you have any uh
yeah please go ahead maria maria please
go ahead
yeah and i'll just briefly mention that
maria is a
student um
i think can you even meet yourself maria
yeah
hi everyone
i am maria and i'm a student of
biotechnology in brazil at university of
brasilia and nice to meet you all
and i will put my presentation here
right now
uh one second maria we will get to your
presentation i was wondering if you just
had
anything to add about
you know how does a student go from just
learning you know doing what i'm told
to participating in some research what
do you think oh
my experience was very different because
i had
classes at university about
bioinformatics but you it wasn't my
focus at all uh i wanted to study plant
sciences and everything like
but then i started to compete with
synthetic biology
and i
faced this challenge to learn by myself
all the tools that i haven't learned at
university and was a very interesting um
moment like
of
doing
things by myself and going to the
internet and researching and then um
i
tried to talk to professors there are
experts in the area but it was a very
challenging experience in bioinformatics
and it's still hard for me
yeah i wanted i wanted to add since we
are coming from the same background
because i didn't have any bioinformatics
at all
as an undergraduate so i didn't have i
didn't even have the
inspiration the where where to go to
about the
the bioinformatics but but as you said
if you either either either if you're
exposed to or not i think that
motivation that that drives is what
really can get you to
accomplish the goal so
you said that you from the beginning you
were interested in plant science which
for me i was really not interested in
plant science but now we come to the
same to the same place we are interested
in the say in kind of the same
thing in the same the same is exactly in
the same field
and and this brings something that i
learned a little bit with with raja
which is uh
we are from completely different
backgrounds he is he's from astronomy i
am a biochemist
these are very diverse complete
in in the sense that he is looking to
the cosmos and i am looking to the
microscope
these are very opposite fields but at
the same time we come to this area where
the the knowledge of programming and of
coding uh completely intersect
okay so um
uh geo did you have slides that you
wanted to share yes if i have the time
to
okay so let's do this briefly i have a
few more questions yeah go ahead raja
sorry i just got to say one very quick
thing to address your point earlier i
think uh the way we train our students
they're trained to self better
self-betterment is what that if you do
well if you study you'll do better at
this exam
self-betterment is how we teach in
schools and colleges whereas research is
about betterment of the world it's not
about improving yourself and i think
that's a very important switch
i have to say you have very interesting
insights both i liked your uh
cricket analogy
and this was also very interesting thank
you
so i should uh okay
yes it's all yours yes
right so uh i guess i gave that
the the title of my talk computational
programs to understand and heal diseases
and i guess i already gave you
an introduction for that why do i hold
this world view
so one thing that uh uh
happened in brazil very recently
and uh this motivates a lot of
my personal engagement in this whole
story i think
is the fact that the federal government
just announced
the intention to sequence uh
i think that their number is a thousand
a thousand uh brazilians
and the reason for that is because uh
the government now wants to understand
the genetic backgrounds of of the
brazilians and how that can inform
the public health system
so
for a brazilian
for a brazilian uh i always i grew up
with this notion that brazil is in an
equal country that there's
there's
a lot of need in terms of resources
so this this particular event here for
me is really emblematic
because uh we are now at a situation
where uh we are thinking about
sequencing the people
but honestly we need to develop uh ways
and tools and human resources to allow
us to access that information understand
that information and make a good use of
that information
so
i think here we are talking about fields
like big data we're my field is the
field of dna sequencing
and we are basically talking about how
can we make this information benefit
an entire society or
as much people in the society as
possible
so we go
we we have this notion that there is a
lack in representativity in many sectors
of societies in many many groups of
societies
but unfortunately an inequality is
present everywhere
in life and its effect of life even in
the usa which is the richest of the
countries
there is uh inequality
and i also learned this uh when working
at the science internship program
because what we do in the science
internship program is we try to
help as much students with
problems in their resources as possible
and also in the united states several
institutions
deal with the same problem and they in
many many cases they do the same type of
approaches to the problem
but i don't want to talk about
a lack of represent representativity
that may be a little bit subjective i
want to bring the attention to to to
this this field
um
the field of genetics or genomics
because i was reading this very
interesting paper that stated that
around uh 10
of the human genes or 10
of you you can argue as 10 of the human
genome to be well well studied and
for instance has allowed us to develop
drugs to treat
let's say only 10
of the conditions that come out of
genetic problems and so this statement
that i am highlighting here
in yellow is a state that this group
published and basically they concluded
that uh
in 2015
50
of all the publications came from only
16 of the known genes
at 1991
and the
information that needs to be uh
addressed here is the fact that we were
only able to study these uh genes
because there was research going on and
even though there was research going on
there is this inequality in the amount
of research that is done for some
groups of genes
and other genes are not researched at
all that happens possibly i want to ask
i want to mention because
we just didn't have the time or the
investment in uh researching all of
these other genes but again we come to
the same point which is the lack of
representativity of all of the genes or
all of the uh
genomic regions that are present in the
human genome and because of that just
because of that
some people are going to
lack on the possibility to have their uh
their health problems cured or or
treated
however there are legitimate reasons for
this lack of
representativity in uh
in many of these studies and in many of
these areas so here i first i want to
acknowledge this this problem that we
have
in the genomics field and then i want to
address that from the perspective of the
two diseases that i have studied during
my phd and now uh during my uh
postdoctoral
study
one thing that i noticed we for sure
need is innovation we need to think
differently we need to think out of the
box about all of these pro
these problems and in my experience
building the community is something that
is not necessarily innovative but i
think i learned i learned that sip that
that's the innovation that we kind of
need
so now uh
moving a little bit to the diseases that
i studied so
uh huntington's disease is actually a
what we call
a monogenic disease it's a disease that
is caused by a condition in a single
gene this gene i haven't put it here but
the gene is called hunching chin
and the gene that the
this it's a neurodegeneration that is
called by in a cag expansion this cag
for those of you who may not be familiar
is a
sequence of bases that are expanded in
this condition and that expansion
in the dna
causes the protein that is encoded in
this gene to have some different
chemical properties
and that's the source of the
neurodegeneration of
in huntington's disease
because the genetic of huntington's
disease is so simple i would say simple
in the sense that it is one gene only
and that this one single gene has this
dramatic impact in the health of of a
person it was uh well studied uh in the
20th century and then what we had was
the uh
huntington's disease was actually one of
the first diseases for which we had
these genetic consortia that were
established in the past century on the
other hand a disease like neuroblastoma
is a polygenic disease which means many
genes many factors contribute to the
establishment of a pathological
condition there is one example of this
mcn amplification that occurs in
euroblastoma but i'm not going to
talk a lot about that so here i'm
showing kind of where the disease
happens in the body so with this
comparision
of uh huntington's disease and
neuroblastoma
it is
what i want to say is that it is
legitimate for uh this lack
let's say of genetic consortia
to study certain
certain types of cancer uh not
compared to huntington's disease because
remember that i said that the genetic
consortia for huntington's disease were
established much uh before
cancers
because studying uh the genetics of
cancer is more
uh complex in the sense that that there
are multiple
genes affecting the condition
in both cases
both in huntington's disease and
neuroblastoma and cancers
this genetic information needs to be
stored and when i say uh needs to be
stored i am talking about the sequenced
genetic information the sequence genetic
information the genetic information that
you know is written in the in the human
dna it needs to be stored and i think
that there is a gap in the availability
about availability of uh
programs that allow people to have that
experience where they are going to learn
how to analyze this genetic information
and i think that's how sip and uh the
programs that uh in pine biotech also
omixlogic fill this gap
is uh is by providing the tools the
environment the community that is
required for for people to have that
exposure to have that experience as i
mentioned i didn't have any
bioinformatics background as a as a
as an undergraduate student
and in my mind that has not uh changed
uh there is some minimum minimal uh
exposure of undergraduate students to
the field of bioinformatics in many
cases that's not a mandatory exposure
but i feel that
i i think i cannot emphasize enough how
much i uh believe that that exposure is
completely necessary because dna is
information which can be uh analyzed
through uh computational algorithms and
uh and so on and so forth so that's
that that's the motivation for the sip
and the recombine outreaches that have
been involved this picture here
is shown
in uh outreach talk that i did at the
institute federal bayern
where for from which i am an alumni
so uh we have these um
[Music]
it's it's it's also a set of tutorial
but i really hear what i what i do and
what i try to do is to help the students
uh
have a sense of what installing a
program is what running that program is
and uh what does it
really the student in in the recom bio
approach really the student has a
feeling of what it is to interact with
the machine and install programs and
then starting uh doing their analysis
from scratch i think that's that's
something that i value a lot doing the
analysis from scratch at this point
so uh
as far as the mentoring
as far as the mentoring perspectives in
ship and and pine biotech that's
completely valuable but i really think i
really value also the possibility of
people engaging and understanding how
the research that we do is important and
here are some illustrations of that
at the zip program
uh
the other thing that i think is very
useful
and i guess i i think i now want to
address a point that elia brought as as
far as why do we want to go that route
so
i i mentioned
i didn't mention uh
to you
but my mom my mother was misdiagnosed
with an infectious disease uh when she
she actually had a cancer
so
clearly
clearly at that point there was
a problem either with my family or with
the medical system or with the
government that uh
financed
the medical system because
uh
just by not having the appropriate
diagnose
there is some problem going on with
either the educational system or the
medical system that's that's one of the
reasons why in my mind we cannot really
differentiate
education from medicine because
we need to have education is the process
that allows the development of the tools
that are going to enable us to treat
people so what i'm trying to say is that
in a situation
like this where you have a diagnosis uh
problem running in your family you need
to uh be you if i was faced with the
problem that
not necessarily we have the best
[Music]
diagnostic systems in the world and if
if we have it as good as it co it
possibly could be we also needed to make
that diagnosis available to as many
people as possible so this is why
i think i need to mention this idea this
concept of liquid biopsies
because in neuroblastoma
what happens is that
the
tumor
needs to be accessed in the patient
but in the other hand
you need to have certain growth of the
tumor in order for you to have access to
what's going on with the with the tumor
and the cells
that's why um
with
a biopsy from the blood of that of that
patient we have we get a chance to look
at many other interesting
uh
biomarkers i would say so here i am
bringing the examples of cell-free dna
cell-free rna nucleosomes exosomes
uh
cancer-free cells so we can basically
collect
these uh markers these biomarkers from
the blood of a patient and we can
basically um
interrogate we can basically study we
can basically understand and educate
ourselves about the progression or the
biology of these diseases and uh
my understanding is that you are not
going to understand that if uh if we do
not understand how to do the analysis if
we do not understand how to interpret
the genomic data how to collect the
genomic data how to analyze it properly
how to develop the strategies that are
necessary to
treat the patients to diagnose the
patients properly
so this is why i think that
understanding the
the the the bioinformatics tools is at
this point at this point in time i think
it it's it's crucial i think that in the
future
at least obviously uh the the societies
that are more uh financially privileged
uh we're going to have these uh
biobanks that store information on the
blood of people and tumors of people and
this is going to be very uh useful
information to have and to
have access to and there's going to be
many many opportunities in my mind to
study that and to help you know to help
treat these conditions in people
so um
geo i'm going to just jump in here we
have a few questions for you
but for the sake of time
um i i think that um you know this is a
very critical topic for us to continue
and explore and i'm sure that we will
have the opportunity to do this
uh soon but um
as a you know as a way to kind of bring
this together
uh maria
you know similarly to yourself right is
a student
that
got exposed to bioinformatics almost by
chance and has a very fascinating story
of how that eventually turned into
something very practical and meaningful
to her so before everyone leaves i
wanted to give her the chance to share
her story briefly
and then if we have a few minutes at the
end we can address them the questions
that we already have from the audience
and uh kind of bring your story to
connect to what she has to say is that
okay
sure absolutely okay thank you okay go
ahead marie
all right
so
i
as i said before i am maria i am a
biotechnology student and i work as
content writing intern at pine biotech
and i will tell you part of my relation
to bioinformatics here and a little bit
about my history and also give an
example of how we should explore this
area being um undergraduate student or
college and
high school for example so
bioinformatics it was part of my under
degree curriculum but
professor papas was like one of my
biggest inspirations because
um he teach us how to
learn about ncbi protein data bank this
kind of thing there that are right now
very basic but
um this is
my way the way that i start to learning
bioinformatics and
but my biggest
goal in university was is to
plant sciences as i was saying before
specifically
phytochemistry and work with the
biodiversity in brazil but i wasn't
aware that my degree was so much than
this i work in communication in
administration and in bioinformatics so
then appears this great opportunity to
create and to lead
an
igen team so our goal was to develop a
microbial fuel cell to generate
electricity from leachate
and this was a
beautiful passion of mine because
leaching is a local problem of brazilian
where i live and the whole problem was
this lychee leeks and we wanted to treat
these persistent politans there and also
take into consideration the other there
are present in the city because of the
brazilian sanitary landfill
so this way we're listening also the
brazilian sanitary landfill and the
population and bioinformatics was used a
lot because the whole project was in
silico
and i wasn't so familiar with the tools
that we need
in the same way as my teammates because
they had different backgrounds far away
from bioinformatics for example my
friends are from pharmacy agronomy
administration
so to achieve our goal we construed to
construct a genetic circuit in silico we
start learning independently
and that's the message that i wanted to
send to you
because you don't need a degree in
bioinformatics or a
pulse graduation and master's degree to
enjoy the benefits of bioinformatics but
you have to be proactive to go ahead and
learn something by yourself and discover
your passion and then
after you discover your passion and
science you can introduce bioinformatics
so we applied computation in synthetic
biology in environment and in
energy because our goal is to generate
energy
um using microorganisms to poor
communities in brazil because we were
born and raised in low-income families
and we also take into cons to took into
consideration like this social part
so
we produce materials from for awareness
about the environment and this was also
a point that made us to be winner of
gold medal in this competition eigen
competition is like the
um
biggest competition of synthetic biology
in the world where we participated in
this version from latin americas and
this was a project that was very
important to us because we wanted to
bring for our people things that are
worldwide you know so we became the
first brazilian team um and the only
brazilian team there was finalists in
this competition and we also won this
best project in energy environment and
biodiversity trek and we are nominated
we were nominated for best human
practices and local heroes so we
um
saw how important was bioinformatics for
our community um people that don't even
know what synthetic biology is what
a molecule
is so
we
bring all of these things together to
make um our place a better place to live
oh and because of that we achieved many
things we had many opportunities to
present our work including at the campus
party which is the biggest gig fair in
the world
and the last few days there was a
version in brazilia so we also want some
incentive grants and scholarships and we
are now changed like forever because we
um continue to learn
each day a little bit and about this
field such as
the omex logic curves that i
began to watch and to study
so i
recommend for all of you to start in
some place even if you don't know um
where you're going to applicate this
knowledge but when you find the right
place and the right opportunity you will
use bioinformatics i am 100 sure
so
this is my
contact you can talk to me anything
and ask me
some question and that's my presentation
excellent well thank you very much we're
already way over time we have uh
scheduled this to end at four
so uh you know taking additional time
from all of the people that participated
but i do have an important question and
i want to start with raja
you know you bring years of experience
to this why is it that the academic
world is so
um appearing to be maybe
closed off to people that are just
coming in why why does it seem to be so
like such a big gap between people that
are doing actual serious important
research and students that are just
coming up and getting involved
it's a great question i don't know i
don't know i think
i don't think there's a proper
recognition
of the
amount of brain power
i think it's two things
i think it's tempting for us to think
that you have to have gone through all
of these
years of training
it's tempting to think it's a linear
process
it's not people can you know people talk
about the stem pipeline it's not a
pipeline you can plug in at any point
right you can
the work i i do most of my day can be
done by a trained monkey no that's the
sad truth right
it's
it's
very possible for young people
to do this work without having to
without having gone through this long
winded training that's a sad truth
people don't like to acknowledge that i
don't know why they don't like
technology and i think they're not aware
of this
the sheer amount of brain power in the
let's say in the
you know 12 to 20 year old or 12 to 18
year old um you know population in the
world it's
taking a person
from that self-betterment mode to world
better and more is hugely motivating you
know you just have to reorient that
person's thinking and they become a
powerful force for good you do that
i've seen this happen myself but uh you
know i i think more and more people are
turning to it earlier i i don't think
the it's a lost cause
excellent thank you well my second
question is for geo
geo you mentioned that brazil just has
this goal of sequencing 1000 genomes
just today or maybe yesterday or the
other day there was an announcement that
the all of us project has released 98
600 genomes that they sequenced in the
past
i think couple of years
so um you know the goal of the all of us
sequencing project is to introduce more
diversity
and i think 42 of the people were white
as expected so uh what do you think uh
the world is missing out on uh when the
numbers are so disproportionate uh you
know between countries that you know
have uh such efforts and countries that
maybe do not have as large numbers as
you
showed in the result
uh
i think that uh
well
for the for the brazilian part i think
that the the actual interaction between
uh the the diverse chromosomes that
uh compose uh humanity that there is a
there is a peculiar case for brazil
because uh there is
high degrees of diversity in brazil
because because of the colonization
we had this admixture of um
these different populations mainly
notably from europe africa and uh
in america native americans
uh
of course of course there is a there is
a matter of of income only
only those countries i would say that
are that have the the
the
the resources to afford this can do it
and
uh for for good or for bad that's going
to be these countries with huge
populations like brazil the usa
china and and
india also
but but certainly the
other other populations that are
underrepresented uh
underrepresented in in the world uh
with smaller populations uh like uh
small countries in africa small
countries in asia there's representation
of those populations in other countries
uh in many cases that i know that uh to
some degree these these genetic
consortiums they they do what they can
to increase the representation of these
populations uh unfortunately in many
cases you are not going to be able to
see the
uh the interaction of the this these uh
these chromosomes uh as you would as you
are going to see in brazil
uh but
in a way or another this information can
be available or this can be
this can be analyzed i think one thing
that uh is necessary is the interest to
analyze and by interest not necessarily
i am meaning the interest in only
investing in this type of studies i am
meaning the interest for people to go
out there and download the the the files
and put their hands on downloading the
file these files which
per se is a strong effort to do
excellent thank you my last question is
from maria so maria i know that you
showed us you do like a million
different things right you write for
different companies journals you know
you have like 10 different jobs uh what
is the one thing you know if you didn't
have to you know what would be the one
thing that you would apply yourself to
if you know you could choose from
anything and what do you think would be
the benefit of just that single focus if
you had the freedom to do that
well my
purpose in life actually is work with
bioeconomy so i want to
help
others come other companies with my
knowledge to make
all of different parts of the world more
sustainable and i think that all of the
tools that i am working on and all these
jobs like in acceleration of startups or
bioinformatics or communication are
going to be some lack of soft excuse for
me to
make the world like a better place to
live you know
all right great well it was a pleasure
talking to all of you thank you again
for joining and sharing i think there's
so much that we can get from all of your
conversations and i think if we had just
a little bit more time we would learn a
lot more i want to briefly mention that
tomorrow we have our second day that's
actually dedicated to
industry
and practical solutions right and so
what i mean by industry is we're going
to be hearing from people that work in
biotechnology industry in pharmaceutical
industry and they're going to share
their insights about the role of
bioinformatics and the significance of
bioinformatics in that field we're also
going to hear about novel
ways to use and simplify bioinformatics
so this is much more accessible and much
more easy to interpret the data
and so if you're planning to join we're
going to have people like
anka maria siobano from the pistoia
alliance from massachusetts uh she's
going to be speaking about
uh pistol alliance's new women in the
stem leadership pilot program as well as
uh their program on
the efficiency and effectiveness of r d
in for big pharma
we're going to have representatives from
the tower bioinformatics research center
speaking about innovation with cloud
computing and different types of
analyses
we're going to have several speakers
from nasa
from
from the blue marble space institute of
science to talk about astrobiology and
what's happening there
and we will have prizes for those who
presented today in the uh poster session
so we're going to have prizes so be uh
sure to join that if you presented
we're going to have some more people
speaking from the national association
of idea principal investigators google
from the precision medicine lab here at
louisiana state university and also
speakers from the puerto rico inbree
program and from the inbree in west
virginia
so again thank you everyone for joining
today
uh thank you uh raja gio and maria for
your insights into this problem and
we'll see you hopefully tomorrow
thank you ellia thank you thank you
learned a lot from you maria and geo
thank you
i too learned from you thank you
take care